you guys have been together seven years
marriages and and babies
hillary duff just welcomed another one
you know hillary is just
she's such an incredible woman and the
ways
in which she has brought these children
into this world right how did you react
when she told you that news
when i told her we wanted to get back to
work in october she goes that's great
because i'm having a baby in march and i
thought
oh my god we really have to stick to
this schedule
because otherwise i don't know when
we're going to do this season
okay so the baby was calling the shots
he gave us yeah the baby was calling the
shot she gave us
uh she gave us sort of like a you know
the right kind of pressure to kind of
like make this season happen
to her credit hillary was still able to
wear louboutins
um throughout her entire pregnancy and
she just like
brought it it's not her first baby on
this on younger either
like she keeps having babies on the show
by the way how did you handle that's
always the question because she was
pregnant during filming right how did
you guys handle the bump
i mean i would go on the sentence here
and think i can't this is impossible
because she literally looked like she
was carrying a bowling ball
you'll see there's some like strategic
you know some strategic wine bottles
uh like a strategic um planter
or like a books she hears a lot of like
she has a laptop
she carries a lot really big purses
first of all
jackie demeterio who is the costume
designer
um was brilliant and created clothes
that would like kind of like look like
curtains around her boobs and like have
like you know
tight black pants and then we would
place like a popcorn bowl
in front of her it wasn't a bowl it was
a a computer
maybe and then uh she started carrying
this big clutch at one point during the
season and just hold it right up here
and i kind of find
her she told me that she was you know
they kept giving her bigger and bigger
things to hold in front of her belly
and at some point she's like my arms
aren't long enough or even just
someone's body is like blocking it
i love it i tried to get creative with
it yeah oh yeah and another
you know there was this one great moment
um really late in the season like in our
last block of shooting
where our director peter lauer
literally put me in front of hillary and
put hillary in the background just
enough
so that she could stick her head out and
i i was the belly blocker
well i mean and what was what's
fascinating too is that a lot of the
episodes we were shooting
um because of covid we were having a
shoot
um out of order a lot so we were
shooting like four episodes at a time
and at one point we were shooting like
eight episodes at a time so we would
shoot like a scene from
episode 11 and then the next day we'd be
in episode five
so we were kind of all up so her bump
there's gonna be
it goes up and down a lot during the
show she's just got such great energy
and she's such a hard worker and a
professional
um that like she never complained
there was one scene one of the final
days in my loft
um where she had to be laying on my
couch
as if she slept over and i as a
mom which i am i i had a blanket like
here put this blanket on let's
put your blanket look all comfy cover
you up cover the tummy
and um it was just so great
for because we all try to take care of
her in the end i
really up until the very end i look at
at her on screen and i'm like wow
you just don't it's you don't even
notice has she been sending pictures
on a group text have you guys have you
facetimed with her at all
uh well yes i've been i yeah i've been
spending a lot of time with her
um and she did send a
some beautiful pics to the group chat oh
in person you've seen her
yeah i came to la to be here for her
birth oh my gosh you met this
what wait wait what how was this oh my
gosh uh it was amazing
she's the strongest most
graceful fierce person i've ever
met in my life it's it was it
permanently changed my life watching
her do that i mean they've they've
inspired how
we want to have babies at home right in
a little bathtub
in the in the in the master bedroom with
everyone else around like
there's just something so special about
how she lives her life and how she
carries
people quite literally you know um
and that's amazing we've definitely like
been on the phone with hillary or in
person like
tips what you got like share some of
your baby juju with us
you guys share like have you kind of
bonded over being moms while working on
the show together over the years
yeah yeah it's been it's been pretty
amazing and she had
because banks is oh gosh almost
three three two oh i think two i can't
i can't keep up i have this amazing you
know
video of my daughter holding banks when
she was like a little baby and then
um when hillary is pregnant this season
my daughter emily was like asking her
questions about
the baby in her belly you have been a
support system for this baby
you're like i will block mom on tv i
will be there at the birth
that's right that's you know i think
it's pretty cliche people talk about the
miracle of life
and it is it is i i had never seen a
child birth before
and you know i just kind of locked into
this deeper
energetic supportive peace in
me and um i just was a
giving her you know lavender oil and
peppermint and really when you're there
with someone who's going through that
the the thing is to just be
be peace be strong be all support
and it was it was beautiful